we love it when people bring their
parents to a red carpet Bradley Cooper
loves to bring his mom so listen to how
arena answered this question from our
Carly Steele
what are your Valentine's Day plans
Irena I will be sleeping working working
yeah you don't show and it was your
significant other um I don't know I'm a
person who fun day by day and that's a
good job of sidestepping a question but
she will be working promoting the new
Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue she
shot her photo spread in Tahiti where
she kind of drove the wildlife wild
there's tons and tons of stingrays and
fish and black to dark and it was kind
of dangerous because shark would
literally fight my booty and the
swimsuit off well we're glad she
survived and this marks her 10th year
posing for the issue they discovered me
back in 2007 ten years later I'm still
here and I'm not going anywhere you
could share one beauty tip with us
that's a must what would it be sleep
getting beauty sleep I'm trying to sleep
from eight to 12 hours everyday and I'm
not a morning person
I hate morning wouldn't we all love to
get more sleep by the way Arina gave up
a cute little secret about the shoe she
had bait stuffed in her bikini so that
she could attract all those stingrays in
sharks you got to do what you got to do